genetically modified foods one of the
most controversial concepts of today's
modern world genetically modified foods
have had specific changes introduced
into their DNA crops undergo this
process to have desirable traits like a
brighter color a smoother texture or a
greater amount of nutrients genetic
engineering has revolutionized food as
we know it and the controversy
surrounding the topic of genetically
modified food is essentially the world's
biggest food fight
Tom McLaury is a visionary he is a
leader within the environmental and
agricultural industries and has
contributed to the development of new
technologies which have changed the way
modern society benefits from nature Remo
Ling is a former vice-president of
Monsanto a multinational biotechnology
corporation as the largest producer of
genetically engineered seed Monsanto is
one of the world's most controversial
companies and lastly stan Bandar is a
senior counsel in Canada's department of
justice his PhD in law focuses on the
labeling of genetically modified crops
lose less of your crop because it's not
affected as much by insecticides sorry
by insects and therefore your yields in
terms of whatever you're growing
actually improve so to give an example
what you can do in potatoes for example
is the Colorado beetle is the number one
problem that affects potato growers
through the genetics you can actually
make the potato plant resist just the
beetle GM crops help in a number of ways
the first way is that's an improvement
is they reduce pesticide user input uses
so that farmers need to plow the land
less which means their biggest savings
then become in labor and in fuel and the
next wave of products are very
interesting exciting because it could be
growing crops where drought is a problem
so you have drought tolerant crops so
you need less moisture to grow some of
these no doubt there are minuses and
there are certainly pluses I mind you is
the pluses outweigh the minuses and let
me give you a few examples one would be
rice it is just a fact about rice that
half the world's population eat rice and
there in mainly poor countries and it it
is deficient in a very important vitamin
called vitamin A and vitamin A gives us
healthy skin and it improves our vision
and without these your defective in
these two crucial parts of our being now
if we could genetically modify rice
which we have done and it's actually
called Golden Rice we could fix this
particular deficiency in human beings
that's in a huge percentage of humanity
and my understanding is that golden rust
will be available from 2011 so that's
where again some of the future lies is
to improve not only yields but the
nutritional profile of some crops and
smaller crops where where specific
countries or continents are more
interested than Michael Dixon is a
teacher at George Brown Colin arey
school Michael is very familiar with the
food industry as a professional chef and
does not support genetic engineering
Jamie Kennedy is a renowned Canadian
chef and owner of Galactica
Jamie also believes in the benefits of
traditional farming and is committed to
local organic food growers Erik Anna's
partner Hannah are the owners of
Matchbox Gardens a small farm in
Brampton Ontario their business is based
on environmental health so the food
produced at Eric's farm is completely
grown from natural processes it's one of
those areas that there's still a lot of
unknowns the science is relatively new
might be it's not very healthy for you
it's been grown based on you know
pesticides and herbicides and basically
steroids to pump them up to make them
look big and red but they're not
actually very healthy for you so many
schools of thought believe that it
contributes to the increased rise of
allergies new types of cancers strains
of flu anytime that you kind of alter
genetic structure with anything you seem
to be kind of opening this Pandora's box
of potential problems currently there is
no legislation in Canada that requires
genetically engineered food to be
labeled as genetically modified Society
has no way of knowing where their food
has come from or what he's been through
I think people have a right to know if
the food that they're eating has been
modified in some way somehow is it
concern
a product that has genetically modified
foods in 2005 the choice has been taken
away from us I think it should be
something that the average consumer
should be aware of is in their foods and
a choice for them whether or not they
want to put that in their body or not
the reality is that we that right now
labeling is for safety and efficacy so
if a product is has a potential allergen
it must be labeled as such but GM is
foods that come from GM technology are
as safe as the regular food and as said
by Health Canada so if that's the case
as soon as you start getting into
looking at labeling something as coming
from GM what does that mean to people it
doesn't provide any additional
information if you labeled genetically
modified foods you'd be surprised how
much of your grocery store is actually
genetically modified and it would
heavily put off the consumer base the
whole idea from the companies that don't
want the labeling their biggest argument
is that they don't want to scare the
public right they don't want to scare
the public they don't want they don't
want to cause until they've done all the
testing they don't want the labels on
there and cause fear well that just
tells you I mean they haven't done all
the testing they don't know you don't
want to scare the public so they're so
they're afraid of people not purchasing
their product at the end of the day and
you know like most industries that
government has to do with there's a
heavy lobby group that makes sure that
stays that way it's a financial
implication you know food in North
America is one of the number one
businesses around its accounts were a
tremendous part of our of the economy
and so when you're talking about these
sorts of things you're talking about
hundreds of millions if not billions of
dollars so there's a very big incentive
to make sure that it's not labeled in
that respect
they don't require labeling just because
it's again it's would potentially be
misleading the people you know companies
like Japan Europe's pretty good about
that
you go to any grocery stores in Japan
everything is labeled right GMOs are
labeled on everything they're way ahead
of us in North America on that on that
front bottom went to the question
labeling is always based on the product
not the process if it's the process it's
an infinity of concerns than other
breeding processes that merit attention
and it's a whole paradigm shift for
labeling if we're going from what the
product is to how we make it we label
aspirants for the concerns about aspirin
on how we make aspirin same for Foods GE
Foods on the other hand are tested for
safety are tested for the geology are
tested for toxicity are tested for
allergy so in other words GE foods are
probably safer than conventional foods
because they're the only ones that are
actually tested for safety the problem
that we had was was where people tried
to market their products as safer than
GM food and this is where you rely on
Health Canada in our case or other
regulatory groups to step up and say you
know it's not true we regulate we verify
and these these foods are safe as safe
as conventional food do I think that
genetically modified foods have been
tested you know
in the marketplace the answer to that is
no
they're fat
the companies that produce the amount
foods are also companies they test I
know
seven years ago when Santa wanted to
introduce genetically modified wheat to
the Canadian government at that time the
Canadian government says okay we'll look
at we'll look at the possibility of
bringing GMO wheat into our food supply
however we need information we need
science to prove to us that this is in
fact a safe product and is something
that we want to use well it's not the
Canadian government that's doing the
testing it's Monsanto in fact that's
doing the testing so thinking about that
their control of all their own testing
and evaluation their motivation is to
get that sold of the Canadian government
I don't know about you but it's not
something that I feel very comfortable
with but my feeling is that the
scientists who produce these are highly
intelligent people who don't want to
have their children have problems with
GM foods and they wouldn't be there
wouldn't be some proposing this of these
seeds to us if they weren't safe so yeah
I trust scientists generally speaking I
can tell you that my experience is that
it is a rigorous process and it takes
years to get these products approved and
and it's to our benefit to have products
that are out there that are safe and
effective otherwise it obviously from a
business point of view or a commercial
point of view it just won't we won't be
in business
I think when people question Monsanto's
methods particularly around GMOs and I
think this is something that is pretty
common throughout the agriculture world
when you're getting into the big seed
production companies and that the common
response is well GMO foods can feed more
people we can't feed people on non GMO
foods or we can't feed the planet on non
GMO foods and I think that that's that's
a pretty poor excuse to be doing the
things that they're doing there are lots
of great examples around the world of
people being at farms being able to feed
communities based on traditional farming
methods that are in tune with with the
culture and the geography of that area
well there's lots of forecasts about
what the populations are gonna be over
the next 50 years I think it's safe to
say that we're gonna have a lot more
people demanding food from shrinking
arable land so one of the options is to
use as many technologies as possible and
GM technology is one of those where you
can actually improve yields you can grow
more crop more food on the same amount
of land as you did with older farming
practices I think that genetically
modified foods are a solution under I
know
I won't agree with with
companies are government's empowering
villages countries around the world
to empower themselves to become
economically viable in the local
production of their food wherever they
are in the world I think this is part of
the problems through industrialized
industrialization of
certainiy jakey modified foods fall into
that category the economies that used to
exist the small economies that worked in
communities around the world they no
longer work because the
industrialization a few has moved the
food production the way from the hands
of families and individuals and
communities and over to
^ large corporations so giving giving
the production of food back to people in
villages I think this was a far better
session we can play all powerful in the
industrial production of food and in
salt
based on short-term game and essentially
agreed by lurch our Western program I'm
certain that one thing we cannot
absolutely cannot feed humankind and the
expansion rate of the global population
if we don't use every possible measure
in our power to increase the available
amount of food and certainly sure that
genetically modified seeds will play an
increasingly important part in feeding
humankind and it will probably come to
dominate the world in which we live in
about 25 to 50 years and we will never
have these conversations sorry it's
unlikely even had these conversations 25
or 50 years from now